37 GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM IS
OUTRAGED AS THEY SEND ONE WAY TO
GET OUT OF THEIR STATE PUTTING
THE PRESSURE ON SANCTUARY
CITIES.
ONE LIEUTENANT DEMOCRAT IS
CALLING OUT HER OWN PARTY OVER
THE BORDER.
SHE IS JOINING US NOW SHE'S THE
FORMER CALIFORNIA STATE SENATOR
GLORIA IT WE ALSO HAVE WITH THIS
ONE OF OUR FAVORITE GUESTS FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR LEO.
WELCOME LEO, WELCOME GLORIA.
WE'LL START WITH YOU GLORIA ON
THIS TOPIC OF THE GOVERNOR
SENDING THE MIGRANTS FOR EXAMPLE
TO MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
I THINK WHAT I FOUND INTERESTING
ABOUT YOUR REMARKS, ESPECIALLY
AS A DEMOCRAT, IS THAT YOUR
REMARKS HIGHLIGHT THE ELITISM OF
IT ALL, EXPLAIN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THINK ABOUT THE IRONY.
IT IS THE BEGINNING OF HISPANIC
HERITAGE MONTH.
WE ARE A LOT MORE THAN A BUNCH
OF DIVERSE BREAKFAST TACOS BY
THE WAY.
SO HERE WE ARE FACING A BORDER
THAT IS NOT BEEN SECURED FOR
QUITE SOME TIME.
OVER 2 MILLION MIGRANTS COMING
THROUGH.
IT TOOK ONLY 50 BROWN PEOPLE
SHOWING UP IN ONE OF THE MOST
EXCLUSIVE DEMOCRATIC ENCLAVES
WITHOUT LEAF BLOWERS AND WITHOUT
MOPS FOR IT TO BE DECLARED A
NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND TO GET
THAT MEDIA FOCUSED ON THIS.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY HYPOCRITICAL.
AND MAYBE LATINOS LIKE MYSELF,
WE CONSIDER OURSELVES DEMOCRATS.
BUT WE ARE COMPLETELY
DISAFFECTED, DISENCHANTED WITH
HOW WE HAVE BEEN TREATED.
AND HOW THIS ISSUE IS NOT BEEN
PROPERLY ADDRESSED BY DEMOCRAT
PARTY OVERALL.
SPACE AND THERE'S NO QUESTION
MARTHA'S VINEYARD BETTER
PREPARED FINANCIALLY TO HANDLE
THE MIGRANTS THAN YOU'VE ALL
DAY.
IN ALL THESE OTHER WORKING-CLASS
AND POOR TOWNS THAT HAVE HAD TO
BEAR THE BRUNT OF THIS.
AND MANY OTHER SOUNDS ALSO IN
CALIFORNIA.
LEO I'M GOING TO COME TO YOUR
COMING TO US FROM CALIFORNIA.
WORK GOVERNOR SAYS HE WANTS TO
BASICALLY CHARGE GOVERNOR
DESANTIS WITH KIDNAPPING.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THIS AS A
LAWYER AND A CALIFORNIAN?
>> INSULTING.
AND I'LL TIE RIGHT NOW GOVERNOR
NEWSOM IS A VERY INSECURE
GOVERNOR.
RACHEL, I LIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALVARY THE MOST INCOMPETENT
GOVERNOR IN THE COUNTRY PRAY LET
ME BE VERY CLEAR BUT HE DOES NOT
EVEN KNOW WHAT KIDNAPPING IS.
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN FLYING AT
MIGRANTS ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY
FOR THE LAST YEAR END A HALF.
WHAT HE IS TRYING TO DO, RACHEL
IS KICKSTART HIS CAMPAIGN FOR
PRESIDENT.
HE IS TRYING TO GET A NATIONAL
PROFILE.
THERE IS NO KIDNAPPING HERE AT
ALL AND HE KNOWS IT IS NOT A
LAWYER, HE DOES NOT KNOW IT IS
TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS A DOUBLE STANDARD THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE USED OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
THEY MAKE THE ASSUMPTION THEY
CARE ABOUT PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE
MYSELF AND GLORIA.
BUT THEY DON'T.
THEY USE US FOR THIS WHOLE
ARGUMENT OF KIDNAPPING IS
NOTHING MORE THAN A POLITICAL
STUNT TO KICKSTART HIS CAMPAIGN
FOR PRESIDENT.
HE WILL NEVER BECOME PRESIDENT
OF THIS COUNTRY.
THIS COUNTRY DOES NOT WANT TO
TURN INTO CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
DISASTER.
RACHAEL: GLORIA, OBVIOUSLY LEO
BRINGS UP POINTS ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR BUT SO INTERESTING HOW
LIBERALS LAP GENT WRAP ALL THESE
UP IN COMPASSION FOR THAT
MIGRANTS BEING COOKED ALIVE IN A
BUS.
WE HAVE TRAFFICKING.
OUR OWN GOVERNMENT IS COMPLICIT
IN THE TRAFFICKING AS LEO
BROUGHT UP WE DID THE LAST LEG
AND THESE CARTELS NOW THEY WANT
TO GET UPSET ABOUT SOME OF THEM
GETTING SENT FROM STATES LIKE
FLORIDA, WHICH IS A NON- CENTURY
STATES, OVER TO STATES AND
CITIES THAT ARE SUPPOSEDLY
SANCTUARY CITIES AND STATES IT.
>> EXACTLY.
THAT IS WHITE SO MANY LATINOS
AND DEMOCRATS WITHIN THE PARTY
ARE JUST SICK AND TIRED OF THIS.
WE HAVE SEEN ACROSS THE COUNTRY
PEOPLE, LATINOS LIKE MYRA FLORIS
AND A DEMOCRATIC STRONGHOLDS
HISTORICALLY WAITING.
MORE AND MORE AT LATINOS SUCH
MYSELF ARE WILLING TO SAY YES,
WE ARE DEMOCRATS BUT WE ARE NOT
BOUND TO THE PARTY.
WE ARE AMERICANS FIRST.
WE WANT BORDER SECURITY.
WE BELIEVE IN CITIZENSHIP.
WE ARE A PATRIOTIC COMMUNITY.
AND WE WANT RESPECT AND FAIR
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
THAT HAS NOT BEEN DELIVERED TO
US.
WE ARE GOING TO KEEP FIGHTING
FOR THAT UNTIL WE GET THAT.
CALLING OUT THE HYPOCRISY THAT
HAS BEEN EXPOSED BY MARTHA'S
VINEYARD AND THEIR SO-CALLED
COMPASSIONATE TREATMENT OF ALL
LIVES MATTER, IT IS A BUNCH OF
BS UNLESS YOU HAVE A LEAF BLOWER
AND MOP AND HAND IT APPEARS TO
BE.
>> AS EXACTLY RIGHT LESTER THERE
TO WORK IN THEIR HOMES AND TRIM
THEIR HEDGES THEY DO NOT WANT
YOU ON MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
THAT IS VERY CLEAR.
LAST WORD TO REALLY QUICKLY LEO.
QUICK TO WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
BUT I HEARD YOUR SEGMENT WITH
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS.
DECLARE AN INVASION.
TAKE THIS CASE BACK UP TO A
SUPREME COURT THAT WILL ENFORCE
THE LAW.
BECAUSE WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
THERE IS NO SOLUTION.
I'VE GOT NEWS FOR YOU THE
DEMOCRATS WANT TO KEEP THIS
ILLEGAL ALIEN ISSUE GOING FOR
THEY DO KNOW AND TO RESOLVE IT.
TAKE THIS MATTER UP TO THE
SUPREME COURT FOR THE GOVERNOR
OF TEXAS TO DECLARE AN INVASION
LET THE SUPREME COURT DECIDE
THIS CASE.
REVISIT THE ARIZONA CASE RIGHT
NOW.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING BECAUSE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
DOING ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> LOOKS AT THE GOVERNOR IN
ARIZONA OR IN THE MIDTERMS OR
MIGHT BE NEW GOVERNOR IN ARIZONA
WHO MIGHT BE WILLING TO DO THAT
VERY THI